things are getting even worse for
Attorney General Jeff Sessions last week
we learned that Jeff Sessions had
actually distorted or lied by omission
at minimum twice two times with regard
to his conversations and meetings with
the Russian ambassador to the United
States the defense we heard last week
was hey Jeff Sessions didn't really lie
because when he met with a Russian
ambassador he met with the Russian
ambassador as a member of the Senate
Armed Armed Services Committee and he
didn't meet with the Ambassador as a
member of Donald Trump's campaign he
since has recused himself from all
investigations relating to the Trump
campaigns contact with Russia it turns
out however that he was indeed meeting
with the Ambassador as a trump surrogate
at least we know that Trump campaign
funds were used to travel to the event
where he met with the ambassador this
isn't even being disputed Pat it's been
confirmed by Trump campaign finance
records so okay fine the Trump campaign
paid for it but I'm sure the subject
matter of the discussion was just Senate
armed armed and Armed Services Committee
stuff right wrong we have now also heard
that Jeff Sessions and Ambassador kis
lyac met at a Heritage Foundation event
in Cleveland during the Republican
National Convention and according to a
source that was there sessioned was
indeed talking about the Trump campaign
with the Russian ambassador every aspect
in it Armed Forces committee every
aspect of this story that we are hearing
is falling apart with every passing day
session says he doesn't really remember
what he discussed with kiss lyac the
Russian ambassador in Cleveland it's all
falling apart that's a pattern that's
the exact same excuse that Michael Flynn
used he didn't remember if he had
discussed sanctions yes they resigned
yeah the new revelation here is that
Jeff Sessions is going to recuse himself
from the investigation into the
connections between Trump and Russia
yeah I think he should have already done
that I mean he was on the campaign trail
he was the first senator to endorse
that's kind of unusual for an Attorney
General to do so I think from the outset
he should have already recused himself
and maybe he should look towards
resignation now I actually am ready to
say it's time to talk about resignation
last week I was saying hey Democrats
should wait to call for the resignation
until we know more we know more and it's
time for Jeff Sessions to resign if
indeed if indeed a second Trump cabinet
member resigns during the first two
months of the administration both
resignations do two lies about contact
with Russia
this is scandal right I mean how will
the trumpets rationalize it I guess is
some kind of left-wing conspiracy right
something about Hillary Clinton and her
emails and maybe pizza gate or John
Podesta though I know they'll come up
with something but it's getting pretty
difficult to defend this it's just
completely innocent it certainly is and
now you have to resort to perjury to
kind of hide those ties it seems you
have a great tape actually of Jeff
Sessions talking in the 90s about Bill
Clinton's talking about the Monica
Lewinsky scandal yeah any-any says you
know perjury is considered a high crime
and it goes against the heart of the
judicial system yeah and I guess it's a
double standard because now he wants to
say on the job
yeah and of course the defenders will
say hey you've got to prove perjury you
need to demonstrate that a false
statement was made and that there was an
intent to deceive and that's going to be
really really difficult particularly
when you've got a Republican White House
in a Republican house in a Republican
Senate and an increasingly Republican
judiciary as well but this is really not
looking good and I still have people who
email me we send out our daily sort of
newsletter saying hey here's what's on
the show and there's people who won't
even listen to the story or watch the
story they just immediately hit respond
and say David you're falling for fake
news there's nothing going on with
Russia just nothing nothing at all even
if you're skeptical about some aspect of
the Russia collusion the idea that
there's nothing to see here at this
point how can any reasonable person
believe that send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show